all right okay I'm that came from
Scotland I'm ready yeah Sri Lanka I'm
you're a young activism according to
change the world we're here at the World
Economic Forum to give a voice of the
youth the younger generation and what I
think countries companies and
individuals can do to make the world a
better place is then they can think
about the things that they must care
about when they were youth like us and
then put that into perspective and
actually be the difference that they
want the world to see and I believe that
the best thing though is enough these
are the conscious and start thinking
that game there's been a shoes enough
and a way that's not prejudice and sorta
similar today I start seeing them as
people and a natural part of human
condition and they also they can stop in
discriminating against HIV positive
people to this a lot like lasagna so us
as our YouTube